this satellite image shows a convoy of
more than 20 Vehicles linked to the
Wagner mercenary group entering the cell
military base in Belarus
here on July 17 hundreds of tents and
Facilities fill the camp
32 days earlier none of this was here
the growth of the base signals that the
private Army is relocating large numbers
of personnel and Equipment that's
following the deal brokered by Belarus
that curtailed the group's June 24 drive
towards Moscow to demand the removal of
Russia's military leadership
so here's how the camp has expanded and
the likely route the vehicles linked to
Wagner took following the group's
aborted mutiny
a video posted by a pro-russia war
correspondent in mid-july shows a convoy
of trucks and cars heading north on the
mful highway in Russia another clip
shared by the same account shows
Vehicles driving approximately 73 miles
north on the same road some of them can
be seen with Wagner flags hanging out of
the windows
across the border in Belarus this video
captures yet another Convoy of similar
Vehicles a 15-minute drive away from the
cell camp
military analysts say satellite imagery
shows vehicles of the same make and
color exiting the highway and entering
the base
the vehicle seen in these videos and
images likely traveled through Russia
into Belarus along this route
that's Based on data from James a group
which has been tracking Wagner's
movements using social media video and
additional Clips geolocated by story
film Jane said it tracked at least 260
vehicles in separate convoys between the
11th and 18th of July images from the
following week showed dozens of pickup
trucks minivans cars and heavy lift
trailers parked at the facility
analysts say their characteristics match
what was seen in the social media videos
and the timing of their arrival
indicates they were from Wagner linked
convoys
the movements are the largest public
showing linked to the mercenary group
since the failed march on Moscow
military analysts say it could indicate
preparations for the arrival of a large
group of equipment and personnel
the previously vacant facility is also
being adjusted to be more habitable
smoke or steam is being emitted from a
stack in these images analysts from
Jane's say suggesting it's being used
for electrical generation or Heating
in addition a vehicle position next to
the communication Tower in this image
indicates that he's being readied for
use analysts say there are limited other
reasons why a vehicle would need to be
parked there
living facilities have also been built
potentially indicating plans for a more
permanent Presence at the base
analysts at Janes and maxar said
latrines have been placed along the
outer perimeter of the tent deployment
areas and rows of outdoor sinks are also
present
the expansion of the camp comes amid
speculation over Wagner's next moves the
whereabouts of the group's leader Evgeni
pragosian have been in question since
the failed mutiny this social media
footage which has been geolocated to the
cell base purportedly shows the Wagner
leader welcoming troops
while military analysts say it's still
unclear what the expansion of the cell
Camp ultimately means for Wagner this
location may play a key role in the
group's future